I'm sorry if it's not an animal. I'm sorry for the equipment. Come to rescue the guy who is wrapped in a child's face.
Fans of the house can't talk about this matter.
The person who puts it in the pie for the time being
is a taxi driver
. It's already crushed to have a temperament as a child
. I can imagine you guys who are crying because the beauty station is crying.
Take me home
ah ah ah
[music]
[applause]
car
dare
ana ah
[music]
tee
me
b
ana
eaa huh
[music]
bond ah
ah wait me
ran
What are you saying?
I'm
stupid, he's stupid, so I can't embody my emotions, and
I'm using in-law or humanity cause classification violence
.
I'm coming.
If Akia escapes and you're killed
, I can't help but you can't beat me. You're bad.